Hello. My name is
Nicolaj Van Omme,
and I'm the CEO of Funartech,
a startup in Montreal doing AI
a little bit differently.
And today, I'm
gonna talk about
this way of doing AI.
So I'm gonna talk about
the hybridization
of ML machine learning and OR
operations research,
and I'll try to convince you
that this is this
combination,
the future of AI.
I would like to
thank the connected
data world team.
Thank you very much
for hosting me.
It's always a pleasure
and an honor
to be able to present the work
we are working on.
So I'm gonna use
two terminology,
two abbreviations today, o r,
operations research, and m l,
machine learning.
Everybody knows what machine
learning is.
Operations research,
I'm gonna talk about
it, what it is,
what you can do,
and why you should
mix it with ML.
But let's say that
it's the science
of optimization.
So when we are talking about
analytical approaches to solve
complex industrial problems,
Most of the people
have this in mind.
You have the data science here
combined with big
data and then
artificial in intelligence.
And within
artificial especially
here in Montreal.
But there is at least
one actor missing,
and this is, of course,
But there is at least
one actor missing,
and this is, of course,
operations research.
Actually, although all those
fields are based in a way or
another on operations
research.
So what is operation
research?
I said it's the science
of optimization.
It's one of the science
It's a very important science
of optimization.
So let's look at
a real problem.
You have a left column here
where we are talking
about reality,
and you have the right column
here where we are
talking about
the mathematical world.
The idea is that
you are taking
a real problem,
and you are transforming it.
You are modeling it
into the mathematical
world. Let's say
you have a city,
Konigsberg, Kaliningrad now,
where you have
seven bridges and
you ask yourself
the following question.
Is it possible to
start a tour,
let's say here,
and cross each
bridge only once
and coming back to
the starting point?
Is this possible?
The great Euler answered that
question by the negative.
No. It is not.
And he did this by inventing
basically graph theory.
So he modeled
that problem with
a graph where the bridges are
represented by the edges and
the pieces of land that are
connected by the bridges
by the nodes.
So the question now becomes,
is it possible to
start from one node,
let's say this one,
and travel the graph
going only
once through each edge and to
a whole tour
passing through all
edges and coming back.
Is this possible?
No. For instance,
if you look at
this note, well,
it's it has three, edges,
which means that if I go once
in the note, I can
go out of the note.
But if I come back,
I cannot go out
without crossing
again another bridge.
So now the question becomes,
I have to go at least once or
twice over a bridge, an edge.
What is the minimal amount of
edges I have to cross
twice or more,
to do a whole tour and to pass
on every edge at least once.
That was solved by a Chinese
mathematician, Kwan Maiko in
the sixties.
And, basically,
he found a way to solve this,
and the solution
here is to add
those two edges.
If you add those two edges,
you are able to
do a whole tour
passing at least
once on every edge.
Normally, the way you go from
reality to the mathematical
world is really difficult and
vice versa. The
translation from
a mathematical
solution to take
a decision in
the real world is
also difficult.
In this case, it's not really
that difficult
because you just
take the tour and you applied
it in reality. So
that's basically
operations research.
You take a problem in reality
and you translate this into
the mathematical world.
You solve it, and then you can
take some decision
with the solution
you get mathematically.
So OR exists since
the second World War.
And most of the time,
we see an improvement
of twenty,
thirty percent.
That's compared to solutions
that are not using OR,
so it's extremely efficient.
Sometimes you don't get those
improvements, but
it's still worth it.
It's already used extensively
in a lot of sector,
of course,
like transportation,
Internet,
the army, the supply chain.
There is no supply
chain without OR.
And, again, it's
the science of
of optimization.
If you think about minimizing
or maximizing something,
you should think that probably
there is a kind of solution in
OR to do that.
So to give you an idea
of the efficiency
of OR compared to
ML because you
can also optimize with
machine learning,
let's take the TSP,
the traveling
salesman problem.
So that's the problem
where you
have cities, the red dots here
in the right column,
and you want to
do a whole tour
visiting each city once.
So you enter a city,
and then you go
out of the city.
You visit the next one,
and you do a whole tour,
and you want this
tour to be minimal.
This is what we called an NP
hard problem. It
means that it's
really difficult to solve.
If you try to solve
it with ML approach,
the best approaches,
the best algorithms until now
are able to solve this problem
exactly with one
hundred cities,
which is great.
But if you look at
solution in OR,
they're able to solve the same
problem with one
hundred thousand
cities. So there
is a difference.
And because it's
a NP hard problem,
it means that if
you have a solution
for one hundred
nodes, cities,
and you want to solve the same
problem with one
hundred twenty cities,
it's not like you can put some
more computing power.
You probably need
another algorithm.
So you really see
the difference
between both approaches.
OR is extremely efficient for
the optimization.
So why is it also important?
It's not only for
the efficiency,
but also because with OR,
you can do prescriptive
analysis.
So in front of you,
you have what
Gartner is telling
you by telling you
that the analytical
approaches can be divided in
four types of analysis.
And, basically,
each analysis is
answering one question.
You should see this
as a continuum
of questions. So
if you ask one
of the question, you
get some answers.
You use those
answers to answer
the other questions.
And this is why
there is a wheel
in the middle
because it's really
a system that is
dynamic and it
is continuous.
So the first type
of analysis is
the descriptive one,
and it's basically answering
the question what
has happened.
So, basically, you
do an assessment
of what is happening.
Then there is
the diagnostic analysis,
which is a little bit
more interesting,
and you are answering
the question
why did it happen.
And, also importantly,
do you like it?
Do you like what
you see? Yes?
Why? No? Why? What can you do
about this? And then there is
the third one that
we are talking
so much these days,
the predictive analysis,
which answers
the question what
will likely happen.
So, basically,
you're constricting
a system. You give an input,
and your system is giving you
a likely output.
It's giving you an output most
of the time with
a certain probability.
This is really nice,
and this is where ML machine
learning tracks.
But there is another analysis
which is called
the prescriptive
analysis, which
answer the question,
what is the optimal action?
It's more than just asking for
the optimal action.
Actually, I see
this as a change
of paradigm in the sense that
instead of
constructing a system
where you give it an input and
it returns you an output,
you are giving it an output,
and the system is basically
constructing an input.
That input that would give you
the desired output.
So it's really
a different way of,
working, and it's
way more efficient.
And to use that
prescriptive analysis,
actually, you are
also using all
the other analysis.
So MLOR hybridization. Why?
Well, first of all,
you have those no free lunch
theorems that basically tells
you that there is no
universal approach.
It seems that it
doesn't hold for ML.
Okay? But it still
holds in mathematics.
But the real
reason is that you
have way better
results when you
combine machine learning and
operations research.
First of all, you can optimize
way better because
OR optimizes
better than ML. But
it's not only that.
You get also more
robust solutions.
You get some kind
of explainability.
Basically, when
you combine both,
you combine
the domain knowledge
because OR is able to
take the knowledge
from a domain. You
can ask the engineers
of the company
and ask them what
they do, what
the field is about,
and you can model
this into equations.
So you get
the domain knowledge
and then you get
the experience
knowledge, the historical data
with ML and you combine both,
which means that if you have
the domain knowledge,
you already can
start the project
without data. Yes.
You can do
analytical approaches
without data. You'll get data
along the way,
but you can start
right away because you already
have some knowledge,
which is the domain
knowledge.
And, basically, when
you combine both,
you can do things
that are simply
impossible with OR
only or ML only.
I'm gonna give you,
some examples later.
So how can we
combine ML and OR?
Let's say that basically,
at Virnatec,
we found that there are four
combinations at least
of both fields.
The first one is now classical
in the sense that it's it's
becoming mainstream,
but it wasn't
a few years ago.
I would say it started around
two thousand nineteen to be
accepted as something
really normal.
So it's the use of
both as black boxes.
So you're combining both but
without interaction
between the two.
You use one and then
you use the other.
And most of the time,
you use first ML
machine learning
and then you use
our operations
research. The idea
is that with ML,
you get some predictions.
And then once you have those
predictions, you can optimize
with that insight.
I'll give you
an example after,
I mean, with the next slide.
Then you can use
both fields to
improve the other.
This is quite technical,
and it works really well.
You can use OR to improve ML,
in a kind of way.
ML is the optimization
of predictions.
So optimization OR is able to
optimize and help ML.
And it works the other
way around also.
ML can improve OR.
Those are two
technical ways to
use them. There
are not so many
teams doing that, and
most of the time,
it's basically
academic research,
but it's really,
it it shows some results that
are really nice.
We are at the beginning
of that.
And then there is
a fourth combination,
and, that's really new.
And it's
a complete hybridization
of both ML and OR where you
develop new algorithms.
The idea is that you truly
understand what ML
is fundamentally
and what OR is
fundamentally and
how you can combine
them together.
And graph neural networks,
I would say that this
is part of this.
Graph neural networks
are really good,
really nice. I mean,
we know this,
in this conference,
but, actually,
it's only the beginning.
There are other
ways to combine
them on a really
fundamental level.
So my favorite
example to combine
OR and ML the first way as two
black boxes. Let's say you're
a train company,
you have trucks,
and you need to repair
and replace them.
How can you do this
for a least cost?
You can do this in two steps,
two separate steps.
The first step,
you put some
cameras under your
wagon and then
you you let your
train flow, you
take pictures,
and then you combine.
You stitch
the pictures together
probably with deep learning,
machine learning.
And you can also
study on those
pictures what type
of reparations
or replacement
you need to do.
You're able to say, oh,
that track needs
to be replaced
in two years. This track needs
to be repaired,
and it's type of repairion a.
But once you do this,
you don't know how
to act because
the idea is that maybe if you
send the team to replace or
repair a track,
maybe the track that is just
next to it shouldn't
be repaired
or replaced right away,
maybe six months later.
But because the team
is already there,
it would cost you
loss less sorry,
to do the reparation
or the replacement
right away because
they're already
there instead of
sending another
team six months later.
This is optimization,
and this is what you
can do with OR.
So the second step,
once you have a map
of your tracks,
use OR to optimize
the way your
teams can repair,
replace the tracks.
I'm gonna give
you two examples
of real industrial
projects that
we did here at
Fanatec combining
ML and OR.
Basically, in the three,
four types of
combinations that
I showed you. Here,
we are trying in real time to
optimize bookings.
So it's for a chain
restaurant,
but not only that,
it's also for
a company that was
doing some events.
And they ask us to be able to
optimize the booking
in the sense
that they want to
optimize the number
of people that
could enter their
restaurants. So
in front of you,
you see effective
examples examples,
sorry, of a restaurant with
twelve tables. Each
row corresponds
to one table,
and each column
represents the fifteen
minutes time slot.
And let's say that
this is an evening.
And in blue,
the blue boxes are
actually bookings,
reservation. So for instance,
this one is a reservation for
a group of seven people.
So, basically, you have people
calling you on the phone or
going on your
website and saying,
well, we are coming
a Tuesday at six.
We have four. And because it's
a Tuesday at six,
there are only four,
you figure out with ML that
probably they're
gonna stay for
two hours. The thing is there
is a lot of stochasticity in
this problem in
the sense that,
no, they are not
coming at six.
They're coming at
six thirty. No.
They are not four.
They're only three.
And they don't stay
for two hours.
They stay for four hours.
So a lot of stochasticity,
a really complex problem.
We created a system
combining ML and OR,
and this is a solution you get
from that system
in real time.
What I really like
is that the system
learned by itself
that the best
way to allow more
people to come
into the restaurants
to optimize
the booking not
reserved, booking.
And so those tables here are
quite empty while
the others are
are quite full.
This was the best
way the system
came up to optimize the number
of people coming.
But our customers,
they didn't like this at all.
Because if you
have a table like
this one that is
empty for the whole
evening, it means actually for
the customers and
people working
in the restaurant
that it's not
a good restaurant.
There aren't so many people
because the table is empty.
So our customer
didn't like this.
And what I really like with OR
is that actually you can add
constraints. So we
added a constraint
policy, the no long net zone
table policy, which basically
told the system you
cannot do this.
You absolutely need
to fill the table.
This is something
you can do with OR.
It's really more difficult to
do with ML.
So solution combination
of ML and OR,
we use ML to do
some estimations,
the eating times, the habits,
how people are booking,
and things like that.
And then we quickly
discovered,
realized that if a restaurant
becomes full, you
should refuse people.
Because if you
accept the group,
maybe there is another group
that is even bigger that you
will not be able
to accommodate
because you you have accepted
the first group,
and so they are
taking the table
that the other
group could take.
So we also made a kind of
recommendation
recommender system,
but it's not an ML version of
a recommender system.
It's a combination
of ML and OR.
Basically, we're combining ML
and OR for everything we do.
And so that's
recommender system
was able to tell them, okay.
Refuse that group
because probably
you'll get another
one that is better.
So I'm gonna cut it short to
the results. So we got twenty
percent more traffic.
So twenty percent
more people.
And we could do
that optimization
in real time in
less than three
milliseconds per booking.
Here is another example where
our customers, wanted to track
in real time sausages.
So the idea is to be able to
track every
sausages individually
and to be able to
say if a sausage
is well cooked or
overcooked and
also to,
try to find out which ones are
the best sellers.
If you look carefully,
so this is a computer
vision problem,
it's very difficult
to differentiate
sausages. So, they
had a system,
and they really
had a hard time.
They had a deep
learning system,
and they really
had a hard time
to train it.
It really was very,
very demanding.
Now I'm not gonna
give you the exact
results, but let's
say that they
came with that DL system,
and it didn't work that well,
and it asked for
a lot of training
resources. And we basically
added some OR stuff,
and we could manage to reduce
significantly
the training system,
the training time,
the training
resources, again,
by combining ML and OR.
The idea is that most
of the sausages,
they're still I mean,
they are just laying
on the grill.
They don't move.
So we took that as
an hypothesis.
And with OR, we could
do some matching,
and, this is how we get,
way better results.
So I'm gonna skip this,
and I'm gonna talk
about the fourth
type of hybridization
of ML and OR.
This is the most
interesting one.
This is where you
have the graph
neural networks and way other
combinations of ML and OR.
This is current
academic research
we are doing with
professor Jean
Drau here in Montreal
at Polytechnic.
We claim that this
combination,
graph neural networks,
and the other algorithms is
the future of AI.
We can do things that are not
possible with ML or OR alone.
It's really the combination of
both that allows us
to do crazy things.
I'm gonna talk
about two projects
that we are trying to do.
The first one is
about the injection
of emotions into AI.
This is something a lot of ML
teams all over the world
are working on.
And then another one is about
real intelligence.
We think that we can manage to
get some real intelligence.
I'm not talking about AGI.
I'm talking about a definition
of machine intelligence,
and we think that by combining
ML and OR, we could
get there now.
So emotions.
We think that only using ML is
not a good idea. Why?
There are lots of reasons.
The first one is that you need
a lot of data,
but really a lot.
I mean, emotions are
really contextual.
If you take one individual and
you look at how he's changing
his emotions during the day,
at seven in the morning,
at ten in the night,
he will not behave
the same way.
If he's surrounded
by his friends,
his family, his boss,
he will not react the same.
So you need that kind of data
if you want to use ML.
And then, of course,
well, of course,
not of course,
but you see that
the data is biased and
we that's normal.
It it's almost impossible not
to have biased data.
And then we're
talking about one
individual with one emotion.
Of course, you want the system
that is able to
change its emotion,
which means that the ML way is
probably to study historical
data where you have
changes of emotions.
You you need that data.
It's even bigger.
It's a bigger set.
But the real deal breaker here
is that there is no way or not
no easy way to control
your chatbot,
let's say.
If you see what is happening
with the big companies trying
to put an emotional
chatbot out there,
most of the time,
they have to unplug it quite
soon because it's going
totally per sec.
And it's very, very difficult
to control a chatbot
with ML only.
If you combine ML and OR,
you can control
this way better.
So that's one of
the reason why
we think that ML
only is not a good
idea. And then there is this
intelligent, machine
intelligence.
So it's not AGI.
It might lead to AGI, maybe.
This is the definition we have
of a machine intelligence.
So we think that
we are able to
construct the system that can
autonomously, so on
its own, change,
optimize its internal
understanding,
the representation of its
surroundings of
the outside world,
but it can do so in terms of
concepts and subconcepts.
This is something that doesn't
exist in ML.
And we think that not only you
can use concepts
and subconcepts,
but you can do
this very quickly
in the sense that that system
can learn very quickly and can
unlearn very quickly.
Basically, this
is what we would
call a kind of intelligence.
It has nothing to
do with the brain
or an animal.
It's machine intelligence,
and it's only one type of
intelligence for
the machines.
We're working on
the following problem.
And you'll see that only using
reinforcement
learning to solve
that problem is
probably not a good
idea. So we have a maze,
and it's a simple
maze where you
have holes. If your agent is
falling in the hole,
you're dead.
And then you have
strawberries.
If your agent is eating
the strawberries
, you get some points,
some rewards.
The goal is, of course,
to get out of the maze,
maybe under
a certain amount of
time and to
maximize the number
of strawberries
you're gonna eat.
That's fine.
With reinforcement
learning, you can do
that very easily.
It works perfectly.
Except that you didn't
learn anything.
In the sense that if you take
a hole and you just,
move it one centimeter away,
your agent is gonna
fall in the hole.
So it didn't get a notion,
a concept of hole.
We think that not only we will
be able to displace
the holes,
but we think that
dynamically,
we will exchange the roles of
the strawberries
and the holes,
which means that suddenly,
if you are eating
a strawberry,
you die. And if you
fall into a hole,
actually, you get
some rewards.
And we think that
it's possible
during the game to change this
several times. Of course,
you cannot change all
the time because,
otherwise, your agent is going
crazy and it's
impossible to play.
But we think that
you can change
sometimes, and we
think that our
agent will be able
to adapt to this.
So this is what we think is
possible with the combination
of ML and OR.
You get way better results.
You can do things
that are simply
impossible with ML
only or OR only.
Thank you very much
for listening,
and now I welcome
your questions.